salut aujourd'hui on est dimanche c'est
donc le genre de l'explication de la
semaine alors cette explication elle va
se passer en deux temps c'est à dire que
dans un premier temps vous allez faire
ce que je vais vous dire vous allez
vivre vous même l'expérience je vais
vous mentaliser à travers la caméra
toutes les vidéos que je faisais en 2015
la mentalisation à travers et ensuite
pour que vous puissiez le refaire à
d'autres personnes vous aurez juste à
refaire exactement ce que j'ai dit sans
changer une seule ligne sans changer un
seul mot et vous verrez ça fonctionnera
super bien de la même manière cette
mentalisation va se baser sur
l'imagination j'espère que vous en avez
vous à les imaginer que devant vous un
grand saladier un gros saladier là juste
là comme ça avec plein de pièces de 10
centimes à l'intérieur il est rempli de
pièces de 10 centimes je sais pas
pourquoi vous avez vu les pièces de 10
centimes là dedans mais en tout cas dans
votre imaginaire ce saladier rempli de
pièces de 10 centimes vous allez plonger
votre main dans ce saladier et en
prendre une petite poignée pas beaucoup
quelques unes en fait il faut qu'ils en
aient quelques unes dans votre main dans
l'imaginaire de votre main ouvrait la
main dans votre esprit est compté le
nombre de pièces qu'ils aillent en a
peut-être de il ya peut-être cet essaim
j'en sais rien vous déterminez ce
chiffre là maintenant et vous calculez
combien ça vous fait donc si vous avez
quatre pieds ses hauts faits 40 centimes
si vous avez pris beaucoup de pièces qui
m'étonnerait se battre aux conseillers
mais genre 12 pièces ça vous fait cent
vingt centimes par exemple donc calculer
la somme que vous avez pris dans le
saladier et enfin petite opération
mathématique oui vous pouvez calculer un
petit peu dans le lit le dimanche matin
vous allez retranché de votre somme
d'argent
le nombre de pièces que vous avez c'est
à dire que si vous avez pris huit pièces
vous fait 80 centimes
8 ce que vous avez 6 80 centimes dans
les mains mois les huit pièces donc vous
faites ça je vous laisse un tout petit
peu de temps pour le faire vous
soustrayez à la somme de l'argent que
vous avez dans les mains le nombre de
pièces que vous avez pris dans le
saladier
vous allez mettre un nombre en tête ce
nombre là il ya il vous appartient
évidemment on va faire un petit peu de
numérologie avec ce nombre là on va le
réduire en un seul chiffre dont vous
allez le réduire si vous savez pas ce
que c'est réduire un nombre s'est
additionné les chiffres qu'il se compose
par exemple si je réduis 861 je vais
faire un +6 +16 jeu réduit 17 jeux faire
un pouce aide égale 8 je pense que c'est
assez clair c'est ce qu'on appelle une
réduction numérologie donc réduisez
votre nombre maintenant vous avez un
résultat en tête résultat à vous qui va
déterminer ce que vous allez faire
aujourd'hui de ce dimanche ça va
déterminer une action à une seule les
correspondances va apparaitre ici à
l'écran balaj les fait apparaître ici
devant moi mettez votre doigt sur celle
qui correspond à votre chiffre à vous
faites-le vraiment vous mettez votre
doigt sur celle qui correspond à votre
choix à vous et c'est cette action vous
allez faire aujourd'hui ce dimanche
matin
j'enlève toutes les autres vous allez
simplement
vous abonner à la chaîne et oui c'est
sûr puisque vous aviez le doigt dessus
il ya une seconde alors c'est ouf de ce
fait remonte à l'isr vidéo ou pas mais
comme j'ai dit en vidéo mais tout n'est
vous le savez le dimanche c'est quelque
chose que vous pouvez reproduire pour
bluffer les gens vedette au repas de
famille que vous avez dans une heure
peut-être ce soir ou dans la semaine
vous allez pouvoir faire ce que je vous
ai fait moi pour ça c'est très simple
vous suivez la même procédure vous
utilisez les mêmes mots que moi et pour
le final c'est vous qui décidez où vous
faites une petite fiche cartonnée comme
moi j'ai fait et donc vous avez bien
compris que je vous ai initié un petit
forçage mathématiques qui aboutit
forcément sur le neuf
vous pouvez prédire à l'avance le
résultat ou prédire à l'avant cela
correspondant sur laquelle ils
tomberaient après c'est vous qui voyez
vous imaginez ça vous fait plaisir ce
qui me fait encore plus plaisir
d'ailleurs c'est que dans les
commentaires vous me racontiez ce qui se
passe ce qui s'est passé comme on vous
l'avait mis en scène ils ont été la
réaction de vos amis racontez moi ça
j'adore ça et j'adore vous lire j'espère
que cette petite idée vous a plu et que
de fait cette vidéo vous a plu si c'est
le cas n'hésitez pas à partager la
laisser un petit poussant réabonner vous
surtout à cette chaîne est fait en sorte
que de la terre entière s'abonnent à la
chaîne sinon je donne rendez-vous dans
toutes les vidéos mais aussi sur scène
le 22 février pour les hallucinations
collectives c'est la première fois que
je fais une vidéo dehors au milieu des
gens et
et c'était très intimidant pour moi de
parler alors qu'il ya des gens qui
passent de partout on me regarde comme
un ouf vous parlez dans la caméra donc à
kayes et rendez vous de demain à 17h
prochain mentale log ciao